let's think about what type of reaction
might occur if we have this molecule
right over here I won't go through the
trouble of naming it would take up too
much time in this video but it's
dissolved in methanol it's dissolved in
methanol and we talked about what type
of reactions we're going to pick between
sn2 sn1 e 2 and E 1 reactions now that
may be the first place to start or the
place I like to start so just look at
the solvent itself and when we're trying
to decide what type of reaction will
occur the important thing to think about
is is the solvent protic or a protic and
if you look at this solvent right here
this is methanol it is protic it is
parodic in case you don't remember what
protic means it means that there are
protons flying around in the solvent
that they can kind of go loose and jump
around from one molecule to another and
the reason why I know that methanol is
protic is because you have a ha you have
hydrogen bonded to a very
electronegative atom in oxygen so every
now and then in one of the methanol
molecules the oxygen can steal the
oxygen can steal hydrogen's can steal
hydrogen's electron and then the
hydrogen itself without the electron the
hydrogen proton will be flying around
because it doesn't have a neutron so
this is a protic solvent now you might
say well does anything with a hydrogen
would that be protic and the answer is
no if you have a bunch of hydrogen's
bonded to just carbons that is not
protic carbon is not so electronegative
that it could steal a hydrogen's
electron and have the hydrogen's
floating around so a big giveaway is
hydrogen bonded to a very
electronegative atom like oxygen so this
is protic and when we think about
product out of all the reactions we
studied that favors that favors so this
this makes us well even a better way to
think about it is it dis favors so it
tells us that we it's it's unlikely
unlikely to have an sn2 or an e2
reaction and the logic there is an sn2
reaction needs a strong nucleophile an
e2 reaction needs a strong base now if
you have protons flying around the
nucleophile or the base is likely to
react
with the proton so it wouldn't it would
not be likely to react with the
substrate itself so product solution
you're unlikely to have an sn2 or e2 but
you are likely to have what you are
likely to have is an sn1 or an e1
reaction both of these need the leaving
group to leave on its own and actually
having protons around might help to
stabilize the leaving group to some
degree so it makes sn2 e2 unlikely sn1
e1 a little more likely so so far these
are good candidates now the next thing
to think about is to just look at the
leaving group itself or see if there is
and there you see if there is even a
delete a leaving group and over here
everything we see on this molecule is
either a carbon or hydrogen except for
except for this iodine right here except
for this iodine right here and we know
that iodide is a good leaving group so
this so far well a good leaving group
does not it does not make it any less
likely that you'd have sn2 or e2 both of
those can do well with a good leaving
group but then it's a necessary
requirement for an sn1 or an e1 reaction
remember an sn1 and e1 and both of them
the first step is that the leaving group
leaves on its own that is the rate
determining step so that's a requirement
for sn1 or e1 so it still looks likely
we haven't seen anything that would make
us think that we wouldn't have an sn1 or
e1 this is a good leaving group let me
write here good good leaving good
leaving group now the last thing we can
think about right here is the carbon
that we might be leaving from so far
everything is pointing in the sn1 and e1
direction the kind of the final thing is
when this leaving group leaves it's
going to form a carbo cation from the
carbon that it's bonded to right now and
in order for that carbo cation to be
reasonably stable at minimum it should
be a secondary carbo cation bonded to at
least two carbons but ideally would be
bonded to three carbons via tertiary
carbon now the carbon that the leaving
group is bonded to the carbon that the
leaving group is bonded to is a tertiary
carbon it's bonded to one two three
carbons so it is a tertiary carbon so it
would actually it can actually be a
stable carbon
cations it's a tertiary carbon which it
once again favors sn1 and e1 so all of
the clues here tell us that sn1 and e1
are going to happen and actually they'll
both happen so let's think about the
mechanism so the very first step in the
very first step the leaving group leaves
in either one of these reactions so if
we look at the iodine it already has 7
valence electrons 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 and in
the first step the rate determining step
of the sn1 or e1 reaction the iodine is
going to nab an electron off the carbon
I'll do that electron in in green right
over there that's going to get nabbed
onto the iodine to make iodide and then
that carbon is going to lose an electron
and become a carbo cation so after that
very first step we have something that
looks like this so that's our molecule
so you can just so clear what we did
this arrow I'll do all the way over here
so it's clear that this is our this is
our next step and what's happened here
the our car our tertiary carbon has lost
its electron so now this carbon right
here has a positive charge
it's a tertiary carbo cation and now the
iodine has become iodide it has left it
has left the molecule so it had its
original 7 valence electrons 1 2 3 4 5 6
7
it nabbed one more electron from the
carbon and now it is I want to do that
in green and nab one more electron from
the carbon now it is the iodine and if
the iodide anion and the next so this is
this step right here is common to both
sn1 and e1 reaction the leaving group
has to leave now after this they start
to diverge in an sn1 the leaving group
essentially gets substituted with a weak
nucleophile in an e1 a weak base trips
off one of the beta hydrogen's and forms
an alkene so let's do them separately
let's do them separately so over here
I'm going to do the sn1 I'm going to the
sn1 and on the right hand side I will do
I will do
be one reaction so let me start over
here
so the sn1 is starting over here at this
step I'll just redo this step over here
so this has a positive charge that has a
positive charge here the iodide has left
so the iodide has left I don't have to
draw up its valence electrons anymore
and what's going to happen next we're
going to get substituted with the weak
base and the weak base here is actually
the methanol the weak base here is the
methanol so let me draw some methanol
here so let me draw some methanol it's
got two unbonded pairs of electrons and
one of them it's a weak base it was
willing to give an electron but you know
it does it has a partial negative charge
over here because oxygen is
electronegative but doesn't have a full
negative charge so it's not a strong
nucleophile but it can donate an
electron to this carbon cation and
that's what is going to happen it will
donate an electron to this carbon cation
and then after that happens after that
happens it will look like this so that's
our original molecule now this now this
magenta electron has been donated to the
carbo cation the other end of it is this
blue electron right here on the oxygen
it is now bonded that is our oxygen
here's that other pair of electrons on
that oxygen and it is bonded to a
hydrogen and a methyl group and then the
last step of this is another weak base
might be able to come and nab off the
hydrogen proton right there oh I want to
be very clear here the oxygen was
neutral the methanol here is neutral it
is giving away an electron to the carbo
cation the carbo cation had a positive
charge because it had lost it originally
now it gets an electron back it becomes
neutral the methanol on the other hand
was neutral gives away an electron so
now it becomes it now is positive so now
you might have another methanol you
might have another methanol molecule
sitting out here someplace sitting out
here someplace
that might also nab the proton off of
this pause
Aion so this one right here it would NAB
it or would bond with it would give the
electron to the hydrogen proton really
the hydrogen's electron it gets nabbed
by the oxygen and so then that it then
that becomes neutral so then the final
step in the final step it'll all look
like this we have that over here the
methanol that it originally bonded has
lost its hydrogen so it looks like this
we just have the oxygen and the ch3
there
ch3 it is now neutral because it gained
an electron when it's when that hydrogen
proton was nabbed so if you wanted to
draw it it has actually those two extra
electrons just like that and then if you
want to draw this last methanol it's now
a positive cation so it looks like this
so it's o h CH 3 h and then his unbonded
pair right there and now this has a
positive charge so that was the sn1
reaction now the other reaction that's
going to occur is the e1 reaction so II
1 reaction once again our first step
open I didn't want to do that our first
step
looks like that so that is our first
step
let me get everything straight so the
leaving group had left so they both in
each situation the leaving group had
left our iodide is up here our iodide is
up here and in an e1 reaction you don't
get substituted what happens is one of
the beta carbons gets a hydrogen swiped
off of it by a weak base now let's think
about what a beta carbon is the alpha
carbon is the carbo cation carbon that's
right over there that's the alpha carbon
beta carbons are one carbon away so this
is a beta carbon this is a beta carbon
and then that is a beta carbon now this
carbon over here is not bonded any
hydrogens it's only bonded to other
carbons so that one cannot lose any
hydrogen's and then we have to pick
between this carbon that's bonded to
three hydrogen's and this carbon that's
actually bonded to two hydrogen's I
didn't draw it before but it's
implicitly there it's bonded to two
hydrogen's now side selves rule tells us
that the dominating a product is going
to be produced when the carbon that has
less hydrogen's loses a hydrogen so
lot of this this carbon has two
hydrogen's this one has three so the one
that's going to lose the hydrogen to the
base or more likely to lose the hydrogen
to the base is the one that has two
hydrogen's not three the fewer
hydrogen's so our base in this case is
once again the methanol acted as a
nucleophile on the F and one X is a weak
acted as an weak nucleophile in sn1 now
it'll act as a weak base so we have
methanol right over here that's a
hydrogen ch3 has some electrons right
over here has a partial negative charge
it will give it will give one of the
electrons to the hydrogen just to the
hydrogen proton the hydrogen is not
going to take its electron with it that
electron is then going to be given to
the carbo cation to the carbo cation to
make it neutral and it will form a
double bond so after that happens we are
left with something that looks like this
this was our original molecule now this
carbon right here this carbon right over
here in yellow it has lost this hydrogen
this hydrogen back here is still there I
could draw it if I like I don't need to
it just makes the thing messy but it has
now formed a double bond with the
primary carbon it has now formed a
double bond that electron that it had
bonded with what the hydrogen is now
being was now given to the carbo cation
it has a double bond with that and then
you have your methanol you have your
methanol has gained has now turned into
a positive ion it has now turned into a
positive ion ch3 and now it has this
bond it has this bond with the hydrogen
I don't even make that electron that it
gave away in magenta and then it has
that extra lone pair that extra lone
pair of electrons so in this
circumstance we looked at all the clues
all of the clues were against sn2 and e2
they favored sn1 e1 so if you would
actually make this if you were actually
try to see what happens in this reaction
you would get products of both sn1 and
e1 reactions these products and these
products over here